so guys if you did see my interview with
Sean Bean and Howard Gordon for the new
TNT show legends that is currently on my
channel you would have heard me mention
that I also have one with Ali Larter I
did my best to maintain professionalism
throughout this interview but I just
want to let you guys know that there
were a lot of other interviews going on
around me so there is a little bit of
background noise there wasn't much I
could do about that legends series
premiere August 13th o TNT so I'm
sitting here with Ali Larter she's in
there TNT show legends which I've had
the opportunity to see and I really hope
it goes places because I was impressed
by it what in the legend screenplay made
you gravitate towards your character I'm
a mom I'm a three and a half year old I
love being a mom I cook all the time I
left throwing dinner parties married I'm
a daughter there's a lot of my life that
is very maternal at this point and when
Howard Gordon called me and asked me to
be part of legends you know I read the
role of Kristin Maguire and I was really
excited to take on the role of a woman
who has chosen not to be married not to
have children to not have any serious
emotional commitments in her personal
life and that's something that I really
wanted to explore you know when I make a
decision in my personal life I always
think about how it impacts my son my
husband and with crystal you know her
darkness of the night she can put
herself in the line of fire and she has
no one to answer to but herself and that
to me was very empowering but I also go
undercover and that's one of the fun
parts of it is that I get to get my
hands dirty
I don't only want to play someone who
wears a suit and barks orders in an
office for me to get to play a strong
woman who has a very powerful job who
has men working under her and figuring
out ways to get my point across and to
do my job without coming across as
bitchy or angry or you know those traps
that I see a lot of strong
female characters fall into I think you
would get along so well with my fiance
you guys would have drinks and it would
just really work bring her this weekend
she's here oh she is so fine yeah yeah
with so many groundbreaking TV shows
nowadays because I think TV is beginning
to get a lot more respect than it used
to get do you think TV is changing for
the better in regards to that well I'm a
huge consumer of television shows like I
binge watch i watch hours a night I'm
just in love with television
I've actually gravitated more towards
great TV than movies because two hours
isn't enough for me if I fall in love
with a character I want to keep on going
I want to know like when they go home
what did they wear I wouldn't know who
they're dating I want to know and so
it's really fun to kind of go on that
journey and kind of stretch it out
with television right now you know I was
on heroes for five seasons you look at
Howard Gordon and who from x-files - you
know homeland 224 x-files long Oh
amazing
brilliant writing Sean Bean you know
Game of Thrones great great great
television I think that their the the
fact that there's so much more content
has raised the quality of it and it
doesn't mean that I watch less I just
watch great shows you know and it's kind
of squeezed out the mediocrity and it's
like kind of all cream right now you
know yeah one of the things Morris said
was it's interesting for him you
mentioned the character and then they
how they ever change and you could just
parents' their life he gets a screenplay
and it's different he doesn't know
what's gonna happen if you get a script
for a film you know the three act
structure you know where it's going but
you get to discover what your character
is gonna do every time you get a new
script right I mean that's not the part
I enjoy that's more of a challenge to me
you know when we originally started this
project they were like you're gonna have
nine scripts before we start shooting
and that to me is a dream because you
want to be able to put in the nuances
you like for me I want to track the
character we changed our showrunner very
late in the game when David came on like
a month before we started shooting and
you know we sometimes were getting our
scripts the night before we were getting
rewrites on set and so in a way it's not
how I would ever choose to work but it
led to a feeling of tension and a
feeling of excitement and a feeling
everyone was on their game yeah there
was no space you know to ever kind of
let your guard down I think you can feel
it a lot of my viewers are aspiring
directors writers actors is there
something you look for in a director in
regards to how you like to be directed
behind the camera or do you prefer a
more let me feel the character out
myself approach well writer is king in
television so you know a director on a
movie King right
you know writer is king on television so
for me I'm dealing David Wilcox you know
our showrunner when I first started and
talking to Howard a lot and for me it's
not so much that I want to be directed
like say it this way it's that I love to
talk about it
I just I really grow and learn through
working things out you know and I just
it's not like running the lines that's
not that much of an interest to me but
understanding the wise the what ifs the
buts is something that that really that
gets me gone you want to know her inside
and out gotcha I want to explore it you
know a couple bottles of wine let's just
keep absolutely do you ever have a super
nerve-wracking audition that just works
like every single one every one okay you
know I feel like I'm an actor I'm not a
performer I don't have a lot of interest
in doing theater I don't like doing live
talk shows I don't like standing up and
performing it makes me really really
nervous I don't like giving speeches
when I'm acting I've had a chance to
prepare I'm behind a camera I'm creating
really intimate moments with someone
that is interesting to me to do and it's
a place where I feel more comfortable as
soon as I'm like you know showing and
you know that just makes me really
nervous so auditioning is way that
usually just don't have enough time and
for me you're not able to have the time
to spend to create the character and
back
thing that I'd like to have I like to
sit in her shoes for a minute I just
have a really I have a really difficult
time auditioning and you know many I've
heard some a different things over the
years and the problem is that when you
read something great and you want it
they can smell it mm-hmm and it always
works against you as soon as you want
something they know it and miss
Laura it was really nice and very
charming to meet you thank you so nice
to meet you too have fun in LA
yes so get the sweet-and-sour rings at
night market I will remember that I'll
take her I'll take her later thank you
destroy me legends series premiere
Wednesday August 13th at 9:00 on TNT it
was so nice to meet her she was very
charming and very lovely in person also
very sweet and very kind
legends premieres on TNT August 13th
enjoy the show guys it is a fun ride as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]